[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king um Mikey
Garcia versus Robert Easter jr. now you
have technically sound fighter versus
unorthodox fighter he's long he's lanky
and Robert Easton jr. and the
technically sound fighter is Mikey
Garcia now Mikey Garcia they both raised
in boxing families all right Mikey
Garcia's family has a little bit more
pedigree Robert Easter juniors father I
wanted to be a champion it was a
contender all right now in this fight
they both made weight Mikey came in at
135 Robert Easter came in at 134 and a
half I believe also that both champions
at 135 um Mikey went up before Adrien
Broner and he won a title up at that
weight class and then he came back down
to fight Robert Easter because he didn't
want to relinquish there's 135 title so
Robert East has been calling out this
fight I think in this fight Mikey should
be the lead dog going in he's at a side
I believe in this fight
Robert Easter needs a little bit more
seasoning in my opinion but if he can
bring it in this fight obviously believe
that he can pull it off my fight
prediction going into this fight is
Mikey does everything right he's not
super flashy he's not one of those
fighters that is gonna while you with
his power but he can place shots and
Mikey doesn't waste punches he parries
he slips he dips he slides and he always
countering left hook is lethal right
hand is pretty decent jab is always
there
now Robert Easter this is where the wild
card comes in he punches
make volume he doesn't he punched to go
through the target he punches for
contact Mike he punches through the
target when he throws he throws to shore
so in this fight
I believe that keys to win for Mikey
would be to stay in the pocket force
Robert Easter to make a mistake and
force him to get anxious under the
lights and then capitalize on it
- I see knockdowns probably from both
sides
Robert East is key to win in this fight
fight tall fight lanky fight at a
distance he is 511 Mikey is 5/6 he
should be using his long reach to keep
him at a distance to throw the jab shoot
the right hand over the top and move to
the side keep the work rate tight now my
prediction for the fight I haven't in
the heart over this because my key in my
opinion quit and I fight with Orlando
cielito after his nose got broke um I
believe Mikey would win this fight
by a decision I see a couple of
knockdowns in his fight on either side
he can go either side
I don't believe Robert Easter because he
used to spar with Adrien Broner and he
was on a lot of Adrien Broner
promotional cards I believe that hurt
him because he fights out of the Philly
crab shell mentality with the shoulder
trying to fight like Floyd then that
Floyd they can't fight like Floyd Mike
is a traditional box that he fights in a
traditional stance so I believe that he
has the edge Robert Easter needs to
pressure him throw volumes of punches
and if he can win on points I don't
think that's gonna happen
I believe Mikey pulls it out by decision
probably it will be a split decision
they probably have two judges picking
Mikey over Robert East in June combat
talk with the king
[Applause]
[Music]